[Música]
tan solo un día después de que fuera
presentado el informe de la comisión de
la verdad que concluyó que la
desaparición de los 43 estudiantes de
ayotzinapa ocurriera en 2014 fue un
crimen de estado fue detenido jesús
murillo karam en ese entonces procurador
su captura fue determinada por el juez
marco antonio fuerte por delitos de
desaparición forzada tortura y delitos
contra la administración de justicia la
fiscalía argumentó que su captura se
debía a posible riesgo de fuga otras 83
órdenes de aprensión en el estado de
guerrero fueron emitidas contra mandos
militares contra personal de tropas
policías locales policías estatales así
como autoridades administrativas y
judiciales
se trata sin duda alguna de un avance
significativo en esta investigación de
este caso y también es muy significativo
que sea catalogado por primera vez como
un crimen de estado más detalles en el
siguiente informe que realizó la
redacción de france 24
prisión preventiva para jesús murillo
karam un juez de ciudad de mexico ordenó
que el ex procurador general permanezca
preso hasta el miércoles por presunta
obstrucción a la justicia
desaparición forzada y tortura en el
caso ayotzinapa el sábado la fiscalía
había ordenado la detención de quien
había ejercido el cargo de procurador
durante el gobierno del ex presidente
enrique peña nieto-
se trata de un hito en el caso
catalogado como crimen de estado por la
comisión de la verdad mexicana al ser el
primer arresto de alto nivel murillo fue
cuestionado por liderar la investigación
sobre la desaparición en 2014 de los 43
estudiantes de iguala en el oeste del
territorio mexicano se ha logrado la
pesquisa concluyó en 2015 que los
jóvenes habían sido secuestrados por
supuestos integrantes del cartel
guerreros unidos según la denominada
como verdad histórica el grupo los
habría asesinado y luego habrían sido
girados sus cuerpos
una versión desmentida por expertos
independientes e incluso rechazada por
la onu y las 6h que es un primer paso
para que haya justicia para que se
castigue a quienes
cometieron ese crimen crimen de estado y
también para que se esclarezca lo que
sucedió esa terrible noche en 2015
murillo aseguró continuar con la
investigación hasta detener a los
culpables una promesa incumplida que
siete años después parece comenzar a
materializarse con las órdenes de
captura
el exprocurador sino de al menos 80
militares y policías funcionarios
estatales y miembros del cartel
guerreros unidos todos involucrados en
el crimen
pues este caso ha consternado a la
sociedad mexicana el informe de la
comisión de la verdad
las capturas recientes y también estas
primeras detenciones denotan un avance
en esta investigación es algo muy
significativo si se tiene en cuenta que
desde el año 2014 se ha hablado de
corrupción de impunidad de presuntos
vínculos con el narcotráfico y
acusaciones de todo tipo contra
funcionarios contra militares y contra
otras personalidades allí en mexico para
muchos se trata de uno de los mayores
escándalos de derechos humanos en la
historia reciente de ese país
latinoamericano
entonces qué significa este avance para
esta investigación quienes van a pagar
por este crimen sabremos exactamente qué
fue lo que ocurrió y cómo por qué estado
todo esto que ocurrió en septiembre del
2014 pues lo vamos a analizar y para
ello hemos invitado a eddy olivares efe
reto ella es directora ejecutiva de
amnistía internacional méxico y también
está con nosotros juan obra yo la obra
arrolla él es periodista especializado
en temas relacionados con las fuerzas
armadas y seguridad ambos entran en la
ciudad de mexico les recuerdo que
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar todos sus
comentarios y preguntas a través de las
redes sociales no se encuentran en
twitter en instagram en facebook en
donde nos encuentran como france24 guión
bajo s arroba santi logo que es mi
cuenta personal la etiqueta es el
numeral el debate efe 24 en youtube
también pueden seguir nuestra señal en
streaming aprovecho para saludar a las
personas que también nos están
escuchando a través de nuestro podcast
todos los contenidos de nuestro programa
ya están disponibles en app el podcast
spotify deezer y tuning
comienza entonces dándole la bienvenida
a edita allí en la capital mexicana
gracias por acompañarnos en el programa
punto de partida herida un crimen de
estado así ya lo ha catalogado esta
investigación qué significa esto para
este caso en particular para la
resolución de todo este caso y poner fin
a este capítulo tan oscuro para la
sociedad mexicana
y bueno pues muy buenas tardes muchas
gracias por poner atención y saludos a
tu audiencia también por poner atención
a este grandísimo evento que sucedió en
méxico desde hace ocho años yo quisiera
iniciar
recordándonos que pues los avances que
se han dado en esta investigación y el
reconocimiento por parte del estado
mexicano justamente de que este fue un
crimen de estado se lo debemos a las
familias a las familias a las mamás a
los papás ya los familiares de los 43
estudiantes desaparecidos de lotina para
que no han dejado de luchar durante casi
ocho años para exigirle al estado lo que
es su deber entrarle es verdad que
sucedió la noche del 26 de septiembre y
los días posteriores para darles
justicia es decir investigar y sancionar
a quienes resulten responsables tanto de
la desaparición como de todas las
omisiones que se cometieron en la
investigación incluyendo la famosa
verdad histórica
y también acceso a garantías de no
repetición de manera que estamos en
efecto frente a un importante momento en
donde el estado mexicano reconoce que la
verdad histórica que construyó el
gobierno anterior la administración de
enrique peña nieto- de peña nieto no era
tal verdad y por supuesto también el
reconocimiento de que es un crimen de
estado sin embargo también debo decir
que hay pendientes importantes es decir
hay 40 estudiantes que aún no han sido
localizados es deber del estado dar con
el paradero de sus estudiantes también
hay que hacer una investigación apegada
a derecho y garantías de no repetición
en este país hay más de 110 personas
desaparecidas y pensemos que hay más de
110 mil familias que también están
buscando les y yo perdón que hago un
poco de la palabra pero decir que el día
de hoy también con compensar debemos
decir que lamentamos que se haya hecho
público él hizo el día de hoy público
que las familias no habían sido
informadas de los hallazgos del informe
de la comisión de la verdad se enteraron
como nos enteramos nosotras el mismo 18
de agosto y aquí se hacen un
señalamiento de que el estado mexicano
está faltando a un deber de darle
información previamente a las familias
antes de publicar un informe de esta
naturaleza importante es ese punto edith
saludado ahora a juan o barro ya creo
que ahora sí ya lo dije correctamente
ibarrola en la ciudad de méxico juan
bienvenido gracias por acompañarnos
punto de partida también para el
programa qué significa para usted desde
su análisis
estos avances recientes la captura del
ex procurador y la captura y la
presentación de este informe en donde
pues se aclaran un poco más los hechos y
la publicación de estos 83 órdenes de
captura contra diferentes
funcionarios allí en el estado de
guerrero en mexico
gracias santiago te saludo a ti y de tu
auto a víctor yo soy juan ibarrola es mi
apellido se que es un poco complicado
soy juan ibarrola y lo saludo con gusto
efectivamente se presenta una
una
la circunstancia donde se menciona que
hay un crimen de estado
desafortunadamente ilegalmente en méxico
no existe o no se tipifica el delito de
crimen de estado es decir el estado no
puede demandar al propio estado mexicano
ya que el estado mexicano somos
absolutamente todos los que vivimos y
los que participamos en actividades de
este país sin embargo es muy importante
el paso que este gobierno quiso intentar
en función de buscar una verdad
y creo que aquí lo y coincido mucho con
él en que la parte más importante de
este asunto penoso grave ya muy muy de
mucho tiempo
finalmente las familias
ya el gobierno actual entre lópez
obrador
ya lo aceptó es decir estos 43
estudiantes desafortunadamente no están
vivos esto no lo digo yo lo dijo
alejandro encinas se dijo en aquel
momento cuando el ex procurador murillo
karam y creo que éste era en primer
lugar la parte importante es decirte
saber quiénes son los responsables de
haber secuestrado torturado
y matado y desaparecido a estos jóvenes
pero esa parte al final de cuentas esta
nueva versión esta nueva investigación
esta nueva lógica no nos está llevando a
ellos tampoco nos está llevando a darle
un consuelo a darle un respeto y
dignidad sobre todo dignidad a las
familias estos 43 jóvenes porque al
final de cuentas no es murillo karam el
agarró un arma y los mato no es o no fue
el presidente peña nieto- elite ordenó
secuestran los maten los y desaparezcan
los finalmente esto ya está comprobado
de eso no hay ningún cambio en función
de la nueva versión del informe de los
43 estudiantes en el sentido de que
hayan sido más que las autoridades
locales es decir el alcalde de igual a
su esposa que siguen presos
policía municipal
igual la policía municipal de cocula y
en esa parte no están cambiando la
versión creo que aquí
lo más grave es cuando se politiza una
circunstancia o un crimen de esta
magnitud donde evidentemente hay una
violación de derechos humanos porque
insisto eran funcionarios públicos los
que ordenaron detener los seis que los
detuvieron claros que los a los que los
torturaron
cuando comienzo a ver y armando este
rompecabezas comienzo entonces por el
informe en esta categoría de crimen de
estado para las personas que están un
poco más ajenas a la realidad y a la
justicia mexicana esto entonces a la luz
del derecho que significaría ya que
compromete al estado mexicano
a raíz de esta investigación cómo debe
responder entonces el estado una vez
este informe cataloga este crimen esta
desaparición esta muerte de estos 43
estudiantes como un crimen de estado
pero lo más grave santiago es que la
politización que se le dio desde el
gobierno es decir se aprovechan de un
hecho los gobiernos tan tan grave para
politizar lo de igual manera en este
informe tanto el jueves pasado que se
cataloga o se dice que es un crimen de
estado no existe en el derecho mexicano
el estado mismo insisto pueda legalmente
aceptar a alguien de un crimen de estado
y esto es una cuestión política hay
otras actuaciones en contra por ejemplo
de jesús murillo karam y las habrá en
contra de las 86 personas más que
existen órdenes de aprensión pero no es
por un crimen de estado es por
obstrucción de la justicia es por
participar en tortura no de los para
entre tres estudiantes sino de los
delincuentes o de los criminales que
confesaron haber secuestrado torturado y
asesinado a los 43 estudiantes es decir
no estamos llegando a encontrar al
verdadero culpable de estos criminales a
sangre fría lo hicieron no existe esa
tipificación en el derecho mexicano se
viven de estado es un tema político es
un tema político edith en su perspectiva
sobre este tema es un tema político y le
extiendo y le prolongó la pregunta y le
preguntó por la detención de josé
murillo karam lo que significa esto para
este avance de la investigación para los
familiares ocho años después tener una
detención de un personaje significativo
en el avance de la investigación como lo
ve usted
sí bueno yo primero quisiera señalar que
el reconocimiento de crimen de estado es
un reconocimiento político al que yo no
le restaría importancia si creo que hay
para el acceso a la verdad para el
reconocimiento público y político de la
lucha que han llevado las familias de
las organizaciones que les han
acompañado y de todo el conjunto de la
sociedad mexicana que hemos exigido al
estado mexicano no solamente que
reconozcan los hechos de lo que
sucedieron que investigue reconozca que
hubo participación de agentes del estado
en la desaparición de los 43 estudiantes
normalistas de ayotzinapa si es
importante en como categoría política el
reconocimiento de que esto fue un crimen
de estado en el sentido de que hubo
agentes del estado involucrados y que
hubo decisiones de parte de autoridades
y podría ser incluso de instituciones
del estado y no de cualquier las
autoridades de bosé andar también y esto
para vincular con los procesos de exceso
la justicia y porque estamos hablando de
la implicación y no solamente de
autoridades municipales que por supuesto
que es grave sino también de autoridades
de nivel federal incluyendo
autoridades militares que tuvieron
responsabilidades según lo está
reconociendo ahora y el gobierno
mexicano en el informe de la comisión de
la verdad y ya lo había señalado y el
informe del kiel y este reconocimiento
también debe llamarnos por supuesto no
solamente a la reflexión sino a la
corrección de los hechos que implican
que en el estado mexicano de manera y
digamos frecuente por lo menos las
autoridades de carácter militar violen
los derechos humanos e intervengan en
delitos y violaciones a derechos humanos
tan graves como es la desaparición
forzada y en este sentido pues decirte
que esperamos por supuesto desde
amnistía internacional el proceso de
investigación de estos delitos sea
totalmente apegado a derecho porque
solamente eso nos va a permitir que
realmente estos gravísimos hechos no
queden impunes y esperamos también que
pues después de las órdenes de aprensión
de más de 80 personas incluyendo
militares estas órdenes de presión
puedan ser también ejecutadas y se
investigue y sancione a estas 80
personas si es que resultan responsables
de los diversos delitos por los que
están siendo ajustadas lo hago este
señalamiento porque vivimos en un país
en donde más del 80 del 98% de los
delitos quedan impunes entonces
esperamos que haya de verdad diligencia
de parte del estado para poder llevar
estas investigaciones
e investigaciones apegadas a derecho que
garanticen la sanción
edith pero como confiar en el estado
para avanzar en estas investigaciones
cuando usted misma cita a la alta
impunidad que en mexico y cuando lo que
evidencia este caso que es terrorífico
todo lo que le sucedió a estos 43
estudiantes toda la sucesión de hechos
es muy compleja esto lo que deja claro
es esa enorme red de complicidad que
involucra a las autoridades mexicanas
ustedes ya lo estaba mencionando
militares autoridades estatales locales
federales altas instancias del gobierno
mexicano como confiar cuando el mismo
estado está haciendo partícipe o fue
partícipe de este tipo de crímenes que
este es uno esta puede ser la punta del
iceberg de muchísimos casos más
efectivamente es la punta de la histeria
y afortunadamente las familias hacia el
inicio han tenido
la valentía y la persistencia para
continuar en esta lucha pero insisto hay
más de 110.000 familias que también
están buscando personas desaparecidas y
otras tantas personas exigiendo justicia
en pocos delitos y violaciones a
derechos humanos cometidas por el estado
mexicano y por las diversas autoridades
tenemos el deber de exigir al estado que
se apegue a derecho y que cumpla con sus
deberes porque solamente mediante esa
exigencia es que podemos ir digamos
cerrando esta gravísima brecha de
impunidad y la
confianza es una confianza basada en la
exigencia no claramente lo que nos
muestra la evidencia en mexico es que
son las propias familias de las víctimas
las víctimas y sus familias quienes
deben estar impulsando los procesos de
investigación a través de la exigencia a
través de la movilización y que es así
como se logra hacer
y juan precisamente le preguntó por el
tema de las familias y dice que son
quienes deben ir promoviendo y haciendo
presión para que esto vaya avanzando qué
garantías han tenido las familias a lo
largo de estos ocho años el estado como
les respondió a ellos
son
abandonados también a su suerte por el
estado para poder encontrar este tipo de
respuestas que han venido dándose a
conocer 8 años después de ocurrido los
hechos como ha sido el trato para ellos
bastante obvio que el trato que ha sido
para las partes tres familias es indigno
y es indigno desde el primer momento es
decir son 43 tragedias 43
vidas e insisto con lo que comentaba al
principio cuando se politizó el asunto
es del gobierno enrique peña nieto
cuando se ha politizado terriblemente
también en el gobierno de andrés manuel
lópez obrador y lo único que necesitan
estas familias es justicia
la gran mentira que se les ha vendido es
que si vivos los llevaron vivos los van
a regresar y creo que esta es una falta
total de respeto es decir el estado
mexicano aquí sí y el estado mexicano en
su conjunto el poder legislativo
ejecutivo judicial
autoridades y sociedad en su conjunto
les ha creado una falsa esperanza
desafortunadamente no lo dijo con un
dolor lo digo con decepción porque
insisto son 43 familias que lo único que
no han podido obtener es la verdad la
verdad de dos gobiernos que por más que
lo intentaron lo han politizado cuando
un presidente ya en funciones como es
lópez obrador les dijo que los iba que
les iba a dar esa justicia que los iba a
llevar a la verdad
y hoy como lo mencioné de ni siquiera
nadie se tomó la
atención de informarles antes de que se
enteraran por los medios o por otras o
por los de comunicación o por otros
medios aquí insisto los hechos objetivos
quiénes son los culpables de haber los
ex secuestrados
torturados matado y desaparecido aquí te
doy un punto estadístico importante en
el santiago que estoy seguro que él lo
sabe
no ha habido un proceso judicial en
méxico que haya tenido en el mayor nivel
de detenidos como lo tuvo en su momento
este asunto de luxe y napa donde hoy los
asesinos confesos los criminales
confesos de participación de la dea del
fbi
abriendo comunicaciones que tenían estos
estos líderes de guerreros unidos en
eeuu donde solicitaban la orden de
matarlos ninguna de esas personas son
está en la cárcel entonces de qué se
necesita justicia estas familias lo
necesitan es decir insisto dos gobiernos
ya jugaron con ellos pero lo social
final y de manera muy velada les dicen
que estos jóvenes no es posible que
estén vivos que creo que esa es la
principal tragedia de sus familias luego
entonces deben de tener acceso a una
justicia pero una justicia real no
justicia política no al mensaje político
o no a la propaganda política
-juan mencionaba que esto podría ser la
punta del iceberg y me desprendo un poco
de este caso en particular pero aquí lo
que queda claro es la magnitud de la
corrupción que hay en el estado mexicano
y la justicia mexicana en qué momento se
armó esta estructura de corrupción
narcotráfico es las carteles estado
mexicano y que permea wta todas las
diferentes instancias porque como lo
vemos acá esto va desde soldados
en el estado de guerrero hasta altas
esferas del gobierno mexicano en qué
momento el narcotráfico los cárteles se
dejaron corromper y perdió todo el
estado mexicano y se salió esto de las
manos de las autoridades
desafortunadamente en méxico tenemos un
problema ya añejo es un problema que
viene desde el gobierno de miguel de la
madrid el gobierno desde 1982 en 1988
donde se lee donde se dejó de poner la
atención de vida aún ya pesar de temas
como el de caro quintero miguel ángel
félix gallardo en esto fonseca pero se
le dejó al poder criminal empezará a
permear que empezará a dominar zonas si
tengo que aclarar y esto por el gran
amor y el conocimiento que tengo en mi
país que esto no es que esté sucediendo
en todo el país es decir
suceden en lugares muy focalizados sin
embargo si los los gobiernos no han
podido tener los gobernantes no han
podido o no han querido encontrar una
solución en materia de seguridad llama
de seguridad nacional seguridad
intermedia seguridad pública para
hacerse responsables de poder proteger
al ciudadano mexicano ante los grupos
criminales en quien en manos de quien no
han dejado de las fuerzas armadas por
eso es tan insistente este doble juego
este doble mensaje de que los militares
necesariamente tienen que ser violadores
de derechos humanos de que los militares
son los que cometen abusos y excesos
pero hay un dato estadístico no hice yo
la estadística el 89 por ciento de la
población mexicana confía plenamente en
sus puertas armadas es decir prefieren a
los soldados protegían no los que
autoridades de policía o que autoridades
de gobierno desafortunadamente los
gobiernos
no han querido viejo o gran mayoría en
mi país no han querido profesionalizar
policías no han querido impartir
justicia ni perseguir el delito no les
es no les ha importado por lo menos
desde los últimos 25 años santiago y
esto es lo que ha generado una debilidad
estructural en este tipo de
instituciones de nuestro país
entiendo el punto pasó a preguntarle a
edith en el ciudad de mexico por unas
declaraciones que daba el presidente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador
sobre este caso él hablaba en particular
del ex presidente peñanieto decía
procesará peña nieto va a estar difícil
palabras textuales del presidente
mexicano
porque puede ser difícil
bueno yo yo quisiera iniciar con un
señalamiento con respecto a la pregunta
que hiciste
anteriormente ignacio y con respecto
justamente a la participación de
militares ya todo este entramado de
corrupción que hay en el estado mexicano
y yo quería como recordar nosotras en el
ámbito internacional tenemos 51 años
justamente hace 51 años que se fundó a
un list internacional en méxico y llegó
justamente en el medio del proceso de la
llamada 'guerra sucia' y tenemos 51 años
de estar documentando gravísimas
violaciones a derechos humanos que se
cometen en méxico muchas de ellas
asentadas justamente en este entramado
de corrupción que existe en el estado
mexicano y que ha hecho muy difícil
justamente que las personas podamos
confiar en méjico en las instituciones
como señala bastantes ignacio y por lo
tanto que llevamos a las personas cuyos
derechos son violados tengan que estar
impulsando los procesos oración lo cual
debo señalar constituye otro acto de
violencia institucional de parte del
estado las familias deben estar
exigiendo justicia invierten tiempo
invierten dinero y además son víctimas
también de la violencia por parte de las
autoridades y en muchos casos por parte
de los propios criminales he dicho a
esto debo señalar que en parte de los
motivos por los cuales se ha fortalecido
crecido este entramado de corrupción en
el estado mexicano tiene que ver
justamente con que es tan complicado y
las instituciones tienen tantas
obstáculos dificultades y escasez de
recursos para poder investigar
adecuadamente
y que se sancione a los responsables y
en este país debo decir también lo hemos
señalado varias organizaciones existen
una suerte del pacto de impunidad que
hace muy difícil que se
investigue se guste y se sancione
autoridad de carácter político cuando
son estas implicadas en diversos delitos
y violaciones a derechos humanos no
mientras este proceso no avance en
méxico mientras las fiscalías estatales
y la fiscalía general de la república no
tengan los recursos estoy hablando de
recursos económicos de personal
especializado de equipo y por supuesto
de voluntad política para poder
investigar los delitos que cometen los
propios agentes del estado difícilmente
vamos a poder salir digamos de esta
situación de impunidad en que vivimos en
el país sí y bueno le preguntaba también
entonces por por las palabras del
presidente de lópez obrador para
entonces lo de la palabra agua para
seguir avanzando porque ya entró en la
parte final del programa
estas palabras del presidente que va a
ser muy difícil procesar la peña nieto
que fue el presidente que estaba en ese
momento
llevando las riendas del país cuando
ocurrió este crimen para poner en
contexto a la audiencia fuera de las
fronteras mexicanas puede que no llegue
a la justicia peñanieto llegar a la
justicia usted coincide con el
presidente
no por
él sino que más bien el presidente lópez
obrados se refiere a la parte legal de
cómo sustentar un hecho historia con el
mejor sentido es decir nunca se ha
llevado de la cárcel
por lo cual tendría que
sustentado jurídicamente en una forma
compacta y completa pues lo decía hace
rato desde que se está acusando hoy al
ex procurador oa las 80 órdenes de
aprehensión no de matar a los jóvenes
si nos están creando una serie de
delitos que muchos que se categorizaron
en mi país dos años después de que
sucedió el hecho de ayotzinapa es esa es
la parte
sí creo que tenemos problemas técnicos
por nacional de juan vamos a revisar su
conexión para
para tener un óptimo audio porque
estamos teniendo problemas para entender
la idea continúa entonces con eddie
mientras tanto mis compañeros en la
parte técnica van a tratar de mejorar la
conexión con juana y en ciudad de méxico
usted en su primera intervención hablaba
de
pendientes que siguen en camino en esta
investigación y también garantizar de
alguna forma la no repetición cómo
lograr que este tipo de crímenes no se
repitan en méjico de esta magnitud
entendiendo ya el contexto que hemos
expuesto acá de la corrupción que hay de
la impunidad que hay y que los actores
del estado están involucrados en cierta
forma con muchos grupos delincuenciales
o carteles relacionados con el
narcotráfico etcétera no repetición
primer punto
ignacio creo que justamente el principal
elemento a destacar es como el estado
mexicano va a garantizar que un hecho
como el de ayotzinapa no se repita y yo
quisiera separar en dos elementos por lo
menos en qué son las exigencias de lo
que no se debe repetir lo primero que no
se debe repetir por supuesto es que
desaparezcan a personas en este país y
que en este caso debo decir que el
estado mexicano ya está en falta porque
después de ayotzinapa han seguido
desapareciendo no no sólo algunas
personas sino decenas de miles de
personas en los últimos 15 años en este
país y han desaparecido más de 80.000
personas en los últimos 15 años
justamente durante el periodo en los que
en el que el estado mexicano decidió
sacar a los militares de los portales y
dedicarnos a las tareas de seguridad
pública aquí yo quisiera recordar que ya
hay varios organismos internacionales
que le hacen al estado mexicano que debe
dejar de utilizar a las fuerzas armadas
para tareas de seguridad pública y si
tenemos clarísima evidencia del riesgo
para la vigencia respecto de derechos
humanos que esto está significando
además de que ha sido una estrategia
claramente fallida este país es sin duda
hoy más peligroso que hace 16 años y en
ese sentido por ahí podrían empezar las
garantías de no repetición pero el otro
elemento muy importante es que no se
repitan todas estas deficiencias que se
han documentado en la investigación y de
los en la búsqueda e investigación de
los 43 estudiantes de ayotzinapa es
indispensable e indignación' que las
fiscalías y en este caso la fiscalía
general de la república
asuma su responsabilidad
y realice los cambios institucionales
que sean necesarios para que ni las
familias ni la sociedad mexicana en su
conjunto tengamos que volver a pasar una
situación como ésta dejamos los
pendientes a modo de conclusión para el
cierre del programa retomó la conexión
con
también hay en la capital mexicana para
preguntarle la presión que recibe en
este momento el gobierno del presidente
de lópez obrador para dar resultados en
torno a esta investigación un tema que
como decía ha
generado muchísimas opiniones en la
sociedad mexicana es una deuda pendiente
hay mucha presión sobre el gobierno de
lópez obrador por este caso cuando él
también tiene en deuda por ejemplo la
alta tasa o indicadores de por ejemplo
periodistas asesinados en este país que
ya pues ha despertado alarmas de
diferentes organismos internacionales
por por la situación de los periodistas
en méxico
en este sentido creo que la parte más
grave es que justamente en este caso de
ayotzinapa no tiene una presión política
social económica el presidente al
contrario
no la tiene porque cuentas en base una
investigación tan larga a un proceso tan
complejo que significa la desaparición y
muerte estos 43 estudiantes ya no es una
sociedad mexicana y esto lo digo con
con pena
que esté mandando estos suciedad
desafortunadamente hoy no hoy lo que sí
se demanda es de que haya seguridad en
una gran cantidad de ciudades de este
país o lo que sí se demanda es de que no
haya corte ya la corrupción en los
gobiernos municipales estatales gobierno
federal hoy que hoy lo que se demanda es
que la gente pueda vivir tranquila en
las calles ajustada dedicación hace un
momento y me sentí un poco como pobre
era tan desaparición en todas las
desapariciones en este país méxico por
parte de los militares no está
documentado
la gran mayoría de estos 116 mil
desaparecidos en los últimos tres casos
han sido por culpa y por responsabilidad
de los grupos de criminales de este país
luego entonces
tiene el presidente de lópez obrador
a una verdad en el caso
para que las estudiantes
y
tenían presión a presionaban seguimos
teniendo problemas con su con su
conexión me quedan ya pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa retomó la conexión
con edith y vamos a las conclusiones
teníamos entonces los pendientes lo que
puedes seguir de aquí en adelante lo que
falta por hacer mientras tanto dejamos a
one para el cierre del programa ver si
logra decirnos alguna conclusión rápida
para el cierre que la poda más hoy que
la conexión este de nuestro adelante
dice si santiago yo bueno recordar
primero y sigue estando pendiente la
localización de 40 de los estudiantes
aunque el informe a la comisión de la
verdad dice que no hay evidencia que
permita señalar que podrían estar vivos
en todo caso hay que localizar a 40
estudiantes que siguen sin localizar y
por lo tanto este no es un caso cerrado
está hay que localizar es deber del
estado encontrar a esas 40 personas y
debo enfatizar del estado no de las
familias ese caso claro y luego creo que
el otro deber del estado y es un deber
muy importante es garantizar que esta
investigación de las más de 80 personas
para las que se ha emitido una orden de
aprehensión sea totalmente apegada a
derecho es sumamente importante servir
para garantizar la confianza en las
instituciones y que la investigación sea
apegada a derecho para que las familias
puedan tener verdad y justicia cuando 30
segundos para su conclusión para el
cierre del programa adelante
bueno básicamente que efectivamente las
familias están tener justicia cnj
entender la verdad esta acción en el
gobierno del presidente de lópez obrador
no está llevando más que a politizar un
hecho que jamás debió de haberse hecho
así gracias santiago pues a juan ya
edita en la ciudad de méxico les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
ustedes pueden seguir dejando todos sus
comentarios y preguntas a través de las
redes sociales y pueden seguir en
sintonía de france 24 muchas gracias
[Música]